Und los geht's. Ausgabe Nummer vier.
Immer noch ohne Intro.
Immer noch ohne Intro, aber immer noch mit denselben Kollegen hier. Linus Neumann, hallo. Hallo. Und Tim Brittlaa, am Apparat,
in unserer äh wöchentlichen Predigt äh aus dem Netzpolitischen Feld,
Lokbuchnetzpolitik versucht wie immer, hier äh einen Überblick zu geben, was gerade so schwelt und was gerade äh beachtenswert ist. So auch diese Woche,
gleich in die Themen einsteigen, vielleicht noch äh zwei, drei allgemeine Anmerkungen,
Letztes Mal haben wir ja so geschafft, sogar eine kurze Sendung zu machen. Mal gucken, wie weit wir da heute kommen, so. Ich habe dann auch die äh.
Die Linkliste so ein bisschen ähm noch ein bisschen versucht übersichtlicher zu geschalten so in den Shownotes,
wer sich äh dessen nicht bewusst ist, dass es die gibt, die gibt's auf Doc Buchstrich Netzpolitik Punkt DE zu jeder Sendung versuchen wir dann auch immer alle relevanten Links zu den ganzen Themen, die wir besprechen, zusammenzutragen,
Und dort könnt ihr euch natürlich auch,
ähm in den Kommentaren verewigen und Nützliches Feedback ablassen. Manche von euch haben das auch schon getan, dafür auf jeden Fall vielen Dank. Kritik hält sich gerade äh in Grenzen, das finde ich gut, aber,
euch nicht abhalten äh Dinge zu monieren, die euch nicht gefallen oder wo ihr der Meinung seid, da könnten wir noch ein bisschen besser sein, zum Beispiel wo ich mal Gedanken drüber gemacht habe, ist der Sendungstitel, ja, also wenn man so mal so die,
Themenschwerpunkte aufzählt, dann wären das echt klobige, lange Titel, so auch nicht. Weiß nicht, ob's für unser Format so angemessen ist,
das, was man so in anderen Podcasts immer so macht, so lustige Titel herbeizusinnieren,
Aber ich habe schon schon drei, vier, fünf Mal irgendwie immer mit so Aufzählungen angefangen und bin dann später dann doch mal wieder zu was anderem gekommen. Ist ja
Mobile so, bei CRE so und irgendwann hat man keine Lust, immer wieder dieselben Namen in den Titel reinzuschreiben, weil sich das in gewisser Hinsicht auch wiederholt und einem dann doch irgendwie auch nicht ausreichend.
Beim Mobile Max ist ja auch die die Produktpalette Apples ist ja auch tatsächlich begrenzt, ne.
Das kommt noch dazu, ne? Ich meine, so ein so einen spaßigen Titel, ne, aber bisher hier ist ja hier kein Spaß, ne. Ist ja bitter. Bist du uns ernst, ne? Genau.
Naja, vielleicht habt ihr ja dazu äh eine Meinung, mal schauen, äh welchen Titel wir uns für diese Woche einfallen lassen. Ja, ansonsten auch noch danke für die Unterstützung per Flatter und auf anderen äh äh Wegen. Zum Thema äh Feedback und Follow up,
Ich hatte äh kurz drüber siniert, als wir gesprochen haben über diese Twitter-Geschichte, dass es ja da äh diesen Menschen gäbe, diesen ähm.
Juristen bei Twitter, der nicht ganz äh unbeteiligt war und nicht ganz unschuldig daran war, dass Twitter da überhaupt sich gewehrt hat und äh meinte, da gäbe es doch, da müsste es doch diesen Artikel ähm,
Da wusste ich nicht mehr ganz genau äh was das war. Das gab's dann in den Kommentaren. Vielen Dank für den Hinweis und der Mensch heißt Alexander,
Gilliver und stammt so aus dieser Juristenschmiede, diesem Birkman Center for Internet in Society,
ein bisschen mit IFF äh verortet. Das ist auch nicht ganz falsch, also aus dem Umfeld,
stammen da so einige Leute. Ja und der ist derjenige. Link findet ihr dann auch in den. Ja, kommen wir zu den neuen Bewegungen. Was gab's? Was hat sich getan, Linus?
Ja, du hattest ja gerade schon gesagt, äh ein kleiner Follow ab. Jetzt haben wir ja unsere Themen angerissen, müssen ja auch so ein bisschen weiter darüber berichten. Ähm entgegen
Hypothese, die ich ja letzte Mal so angerissen hatte, dass äh Julian Assange eventuell,
Einspruch mehr einreichen würde, wurde es jetzt angekündigt, dass er also einen erneuten Einspruch gegen diese Auslieferungsin zweiter,
Instanz einreichen möchte und dann wird er eben beim Supreme Court landen und da wird am fünften Dezember eine Anhörung stattfinden, ob diese Berufung angenommen wird, also diese Supreme Courts setzen sich ja damit erstmal immer auseinander.
Also Supreme Call ist wahrscheinlich vergleichbar mit unserem Bundesverfassungsgericht oder dem ist es, ist es wirklich Verfassungsgericht Äquivalent oder ist es so, nur die höchste normale Gerichtsordnung so wie bei uns das äh Bundes.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sagen, aber ist auf jeden Fall jetzt das höchste Gericht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt eine ob das gleichzusetzen ist mit so einer Verfassungswächter-Funktion, aber davon gehe ich ja eigentlich dann aus. Wenn ich wenn ich irgendwann ein höchstes Gericht habe, dann geht's ja nur noch um.
Britannien gibt's ja keine Verfassung, insofern. Also auf jeden Fall, dass das oberste Gericht.
Ans oberste Gericht, ja. Und ähm,
Genau, da wird dann entschieden, ob diese Berufung angenommen wird, also ob sich das Gericht überhaupt damit auseinandersetzen möchte. Das heißt, dann könnte es entweder, wenn die da sagen, nein,
Dann hätten wir wieder diese zwei Wochen, dass er los muss,
nach Schweden. Und wenn sie's annehmen, dann kann er sich wahrscheinlich erstmal wieder auf ein weitere lange Monate seiner Fußfessel da gefasst machen, weil das ja dann erstmal wieder Ewigkeiten dauert, bis man dann da einen Termin kriegt bei denen, ne.
Ja, wobei, wenn's der Supreme Court das äh ablehnt.
Ja, da geht's nur um das um die Berufung generell. Also.
Ach so, ob man überhaupt erst mal Berufung einlegen darf.
Erstmal möchte, ob der das quasi ob der annimmt, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, weil dazu muss die Bedingung irgendwie sein, dass es ein besondere Bedeutung äh für das Land hat. Und da, ja, damit nicht einfach jeder Pipifax da hin nach da oben geklagt wird.
Ja. Da könnte man durchaus äh argumentieren, dass dem wohl so ist. Aber die sehen das sicherlich, haben da sicherlich noch mal ganz spezielle Sicht da drauf.
Tja. Ah, genau. Und Schultrojaner ähm nur so eine Ankündigung, dass jetzt also nachdem jetzt ähm das mediale Interesse auf diesen Vertrag, den die Kultusminister der Länder mit den Verlegen,
Verlegen, sagt man, verlagen, verlagen mit den Verlagen,
Geschlossenheit, nachdem wir jetzt das mediale Interesse drauf war, gab's ja dann äh Bienenleuthäuser Schnarrenberger hatte, glaube ich, gesagt, dass sie äh damit nicht zufrieden ist und,
jetzt wurde also die Amtschefkonferenz, der Kultusminister hat jetzt also angekündigt, dass sie da auf jeden Fall nochmal nachverhandeln wollen bei diesem Vertrag, den sie unterschrieben haben und ähm.
Dabei wurde dann nochmal betont, was ich, glaube ich, in der in der.
Ministerkonferenz. Cool. Also.
Kultusminister, Kultus.
Kultusminister, Entschuldigung, ja, Kultusminister, also.
Amtschefkonferenz der Kultusminister, weil da sind in der Amtschefkonferenz sitzen dann die Staatssekretäre von denen.
Ah, okay. Verstehe.
Die sagen, da müssen wir irgendwie noch mal was machen. Und was ich, glaube ich, in der Sendung nicht ausreichend betont hat, ist, dass ja für diese Nachteiligen Vertrag Zahlen die Länder ja trotzdem Geld an die Verlage,
Und zwar äh momentan sieben Komma drei und ab zweitausendvierzehn dann neun Millionen Euro. Also das heißt, diese Leistung, diese,
Anführungszeichen Zugeständnisse, diese minimalen, die die Verlage da machen, dass sie das in Schulbüchern irgendwie so und so viel Seiten kopiert werden dürfen, die lassen die sich ja auch noch bezahlen.
Das ist ja krass.
Das wollte ich nur also mir war das irgendwie offensichtlich so klar, dass ich's nicht ausreichend in der Sendung.
Also das zahlen jetzt die Länder in der Summe oder das muss jetzt jedes Land zahlen. Das heißt, die schmeißen da auch zusammen oder was?
Jetzt machst du mich verrückt. Nee, nee, soll, also sicherlich in der Summe, weil wenn es ähm wenn es jedes Einzelland zahlen würde, dann hätten die Medien auf jeden Fall die Ver,
multiplizierte oder die addierte Summe berichtet. Also gehe ich davon aus, dass insgesamt die neun Millionen Euro sind.
Naja, weißt ja, der schreibt, der findet ja auch mal eben mal so fünfundfünfzig Milliarden.
Das ist auch immer, weißt du, du weißt ja selber hier auch in der Metaebene mit der Ordnung und so. Hier hier bündeln sich auch hier jeden Monat kommt hier irgendwie der Koffer von Flatter rübergeschickt mit dem ganzen Geld und.
Schiebt man hier, macht man hier eine Schublade auf und dann schon wieder ah.
Dann dann wackelt mal der Tisch, dann dann kann man da mal mit dem Bündel drunterlegen.
So läuft's. Insofern haben wir vollstes Verständnis. Aber trotzdem, das riecht natürlich auch schon wirklich jetzt nochmal extra komisch, also dass man dann irgendwie für diese merkwürdige,
dafür, dass sie ihren Trojaner installieren dürfen, werden sie auch noch bezahlt. Großartig. Na gut,
Das war's zum Thema äh Schultrojaner. Ja. Ja?
Ja, so, sollen wir direkt bei Urheberrecht äh noch kurz bleiben?
Ja, das äh passt ja da ganz gut rein, ne.
Genau, es gab also ein, das ist ein höherer Wunsch, ja, der der erreichte mich über Twitter, dass diese dieses Thema gerne behandelt haben möchte. Ähm und zwar.
Hatte die Wiki, gab es in der Wikipedia.
Wurden die Wohlfahrtsmarken von Loriot veröffentlicht. Also die Post bringt irgendwie so Wohlfahrtsmarken heraus.
Das sind die, wo man ein bisschen mehr fürs Porto bezahlt. Dann hat man nochmal so einen extra Aufschlag.
Zeit meiner tatsächlich mehr für, ich weiß das gar nicht.
Bei allen so ist, aber es gibt,
gab zumindest, wenn jetzt echt kein Briefmarken-Freak, aber es gab so Briefmarken, da stand dann auch immer noch mal so Plus zwanzig plus dreißig drauf, wo man sozusagen explizit,
Mehr fürs Porto zahlt und eben auch quasi eine Spende implizit mit drinnen ist. Und jetzt nicht nur wir machen jetzt mal hier auf hübsch und.
Hübsche Briefmarken und ansonsten ändert sich nichts.
Ich habe diese Marken nie gesehen und woran es liegt, komme ich ja jetzt zu. Es gab nämlich,
eine einstweilige Verfügung. Der Loriot Erden am Oberlandesgericht Berlin, die gegen diese Veröffentlichung dieser Marken in der Wikipedia,
ähm sich dagegen wehren wollten und das ähm also warum hat die Wikipedia sich überhaupt gedacht, sie würde da könnte Briefmarken veröffentlichen? Das lag daran, dass sie gesagt haben, dass sie davon ausgegangen sind, dass,
amtliche Werke sind und deswegen kein Urheberschutz genießen.
Und ähm da gab's auch ein Urteil von neunzehnhundertsiebenundachtzig, was ziemlich genau das
betont hat, neunzehnhundertsiebenundachtzig war die Post aber noch amtlich, ja, dass da äh war sie noch nicht privatisiert. Und das Gericht äh ist jetzt, hat also dieser einstweiligen Verfügung stattgegeben und sagt, ja, das ist eine Post-AG,
Ja und die machen Briefmarken und deswegen ähm stehen die auch unter Urheberrechtsschutz.
Ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass in der Wikipedia keine Wohlfahrtsmarkt abgebildet wären. Da gibt's äh diverse. Hier siehst du das übrigens auch gerade, ne? Vierzig äh Cent plus zwanzig steht drunter.
Da, ah ja. Ist aber eine von neunzehnhundertfünfundsechzig, die dürfen sie.
Ja, vermutlich, zumindest hat sich da noch keiner jetzt groß beschwert,
Aber das Prinzip wird sich jetzt, glaube ich, nicht groß äh geändert haben, ne? Aber hier sind so lange Listen in der Wikipedia, das geht jetzt eher noch ein bisschen weiter. Ich habe das nur mal ganz am Anfang angefangen, die letzte, die ich jetzt hier sehe, ist neunzehnhundertneunzig.
Liegt's genau jetzt daran.
Also Flussmarken mit mit Extrabonus, mit Soli. Man man zahlt.
Noch mit Solidaritätszuschlag.
Und ähm aber das Interessante, was weiter interessanter an diesem ähm Fall war, dass nämlich diesmal nicht der Wikimedia EV Deutschland die Klage abbekommen hat, sondern äh die Loriot Erben so schlau waren, sich direkt an die äh Wikimedia Foundation in den USA
zu wenden und gegen die ihre einstweilige Verfügung zu äh zu anzustrengen,
Und die Wikimedia Foundation in den USA geht nicht dagegen vor, weil sie einen Präzedenzfall vermeiden wollen, der eventuell negative Konsequenzen hätte und weil nach US-Recht
ebenfalls für Briefmarken, Urheberrechtsschutz gilt. Das heißt, äh es wurde relativ erfolgreich, haben die Lorioten jetzt,
Media raus aus der Wikipedia rauspediert, torpedi.
Pediert, ja. Ja.
Und ähm man kann sich jetzt natürlich irgendwie fragen, was was grundsätzlich soll, also ich meine kein äh.
Kein wie heißen die Filatelisten, ne? Die Brief.
Filiattelisten. Mhm.
Druckt sich kein Filiatellist druckt sich das Ding aus, um irgendwie da mit den den Soli zu sparen oder was?
Aber ich meine, es ist halt immer so beim Urheberrecht. So, es ist so dieses, wenn du dein Urheberrecht auch wahren willst, dann musst du es eben auch verfolgen, weil wenn du das denn nicht tust,
kann dir später mal vorgeworfen werden, dass wir da eh kein großes Interesse daran hast oder vielleicht eben, weiß nicht, dieses Recht auch gar nicht,
inne hast, das kenne ich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht, aber das ist äh auch so ein wiederkehrendes Meme. Auf der anderen Seite kann man sich auch wirklich fragen, was die Leute manchmal so treibt, ne.
War's wahrscheinlich immer schon immer total egal und kaum ist er jetzt da hingeschieden, kommt die Meute und klopft sich um den Rest.
Noch ein äh noch ein Ding aus dem Urheberrechtsbereich, vielleicht nur ganz kurz, ging aber auch so durch die Medien irgendjemand hatte Ausschnitte des Filmes Werner eiskalt auf YouTube,
gestellt, äh die er da irgendwie im im Kino mit einer Kamera abgefilmt hatte. Konstantin verleih, hat äh eine einstweilige Verfügung angestrengt beim Landgericht München und wollte nämlich.
Die von YouTube die Nutzerdaten haben, das heißt, sie wollten denjenigen, der das da reingestellt hat, das wollten sie gerne wissen und äh
Dann hat das Landgericht München gesagt, na ja, also wenn da irgendwie jemanden selbst gedrehtes Video von äh von eurem Film irgendwo auf YouTube in,
hochlädt und das irgendwo noch nicht mal der gesamte Film ist, dann ist das ja offensichtlich kein gewerbliches Ausmaß.
Film.
Ja, der hat ja selbst also selbst das machen die doch immer, die.
So ein, so ein so ein abgefilmt aus dem Kino. Mhm.
Vater irgendwie wie wie nennt er Camrip? Ja, okay, der hat also da.
Cam nennt man das ja. Wenn man's mit der Kamera abgenommen hat sozusagen.
Sowas hätte da irgendwie reingestellt. Äh war, wie gesagt, auch nicht der ganze Film. Und ähm das wurde jetzt in zweiter äh Instanz beim Oberlandesgericht München auch bestätigt, sodass also YouTube da die Nutzerdaten nicht.
Nicht rausgeben muss. Naja.
Immerhin. So, wenn's nämlich, wenn wir uns überlegen, was ähm ja diesen äh,
Stop on. Ich bin jetzt echt beim Safe online beim äh Stop Onlinepirat, den wir äh ja angesprochen hatten,
und auch bei Acta, wo wir eventuell heute noch kurz zu kommen, da soll ja genau das angegangen werden, indem man dann einmal den äh YouTube so eine Art ähm Störerhaftung irgendwie,
gibt, das heißt YouTube müsste das eh von vorneherein raus zensieren oder wegkontrollieren. Und zweitens ähm solche Anbieter eben verpflichten möchte Nutzerdaten rauszugeben,
und deswegen wär's das, deswegen habe ich den diesen Fall nur nochmal auch ausgegraben.
Das zumindest noch der aktuellen Rechtslage äh das jetzt noch nicht zwingend so sein muss, sondern dass das Gericht auch sagt, so.
Kümmert euch um was anderes. Ja, Konstantin Verleihe ist ja auch echt aufm Kriegsfuß äh mit YouTube, ne. Ich meine, das sind ja auch diese diese Hitler-Parodien,
Hitler Reacts. Da ist ja auch äh Konstantin betroffen.
Das ist auch Konstantin. Oh Mann, ey.
Und äh da haben sie sich ja auch irgendwie total auf die Füße äh getreten gefühlt. Was ich überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht verstehen kann, ja. Also.
Werden sie nun Zeuge, wie Tim Pritluff, ein Nehm erklärt.
Soll ich, muss ich.
Naja, vielleicht ganz kurz oder.
Ja gut, ich weiß äh hat sicherlich jeder schon mal gesehen, vielleicht nicht unbedingt jeder immer verstanden, ja? Aber äh dieser Film, der Untergang, der halt.
Versucht eben die Nazi-Geschichte mit einem speziellen Blick äh auch auf Hitler äh dazu äh erzählen mit ähm,
einer außerordentlichen äh schauspielerischen Leistung von äh Bruno ganz, ja, und dann gibt es halt,
eine Szene, wo er da sein Bunker sitzt und äh sein, seine ganze Truppe da irgendwie zusammenfaltet und,
Irgendjemand hat halt mal angefangen, welche Vorkommnisse auch immer auf diesem Planeten irgendwie,
mit dieser Szene zu dokumentieren, indem man einfach nur andere Untertitel macht, weil normalerweise die,
meisten Leute halt kein Deutsch verstehen. Für uns hat das immer so was Merkwürdiges, weil man hört irgendwie immer dieselbe Geschichte und prazibers Dach ist, aber wenn man dann halt einfach sich konzentriert, das nicht mehr hört und nur noch diese Untertitel liest, was
Hitler angeblich jetzt schon wieder für eine Reaktion gezeigt hat, die immer die gleiche ist, dass er total durchdreht und mit zittriger Hand irgendwie sich seine Brille äh
vor den Augen nimmt, um dann total durchzudrehen. Äh das ist.
Was weiß ich, weil's irgendwie.
Ja irgendwie Apple stellt kein iPhone fünf vor und so,
und er dreht halt einfach total durch. Und was bilden sie sich überhaupt ein? Alle fangen an zu heulen, weil sie irgendwie nicht ertragen können. Also das das ist einfach kulturell,
so großartig, ja? Äh und eigentlich auch so entkoppelt von diesem Film, wie ich finde, ja, also ich weiß ja nicht, was die was die denken, ja, also glauben sie, dass ihr Film illegal kopiert wird? Niemand,
nimmt den Film da an der Stelle als solche.
Eine Szene hat mir noch gefehlt, die schneide ich jetzt doch rein.
Also äh an der Stelle ist es wirklich Quatsch, ja? Dann
klar, könnte man natürlich denken, das schadet jetzt hier unserem Werk und das wird jetzt hier in den Schmutz gezogen und banalisiert und keine Ahnung. Da kann ich auch nur sagen, get a Life äh Understand die Internet, weil
das ist, das ist einfach so, davon getrennt und das ist auch an sich schon mal wirklich eigentlich ein ein Kompliment an den Film.
Absolutes Kompliment an
Film. Ja, also diese Szene ist ja auch unglaublich eindrucksvoll. Die ist ja wirklich eine wahnsinnige Schauspielerische Leistung. Und das sieht ja auch jeder, der das, der es irgendwie schaut, okay, das irgendwie mit Humor zu verbinden, ja, ist eben Internet, ne, da wird auch mal ein Scherz gemacht. Äh.
Ja, es gibt Humor im Internet.
Und genau und dagegen gehen sie auch immer vor. Oder ähm.
Ja, sie haben halt versucht, äh haben wir halt sie sind nicht ausgesprochen erfolgreich dabei, aber es verschwindet halt äh periodisch verschwinden halt immer wieder irgendwelche Parodien, nur um dann halt an anderer Stelle gleich wieder hochgeladen zu werden.
Da gab's aber natürlich auch irgendwo dann diesen äh Hit. Da erfährt das Konstantin Film, die Hela Parodien von YouTube.
Genau, es ist einfach auch super Selbstrefferziell und an der Stelle schaden sie sich natürlich auch, mit diesem Streusand-Effekt. Es ist äh ja, es macht einfach echt schlechtes Image und es war an der Stelle meiner Meinung nach auch wirklich komplett.
Quatsch. Schlicht beraten sind diese Unternehmen, ja?
Vielleicht wäre es angemessen, dass sich wirklich jeder mit ausreichend intellektuell und und Urheberrecht ausgestattet sich mal so ein Internetberater äh holt, der irgendwie die ersten fünf Jahre seines Lebens einfach nur auf Forschern abgehangen hat
weil da kann man dann einfach noch eine Menge lernen und verstehen. Und soweit sind wir, glaube ich, noch nicht. Gut, ja, du hast also ich,
dieses Acta-Fass, das machen wir jetzt nicht äh aus, ja? Äh auf da sollte man, glaube ich, nochmal separat äh zu reden, wenn man ein bisschen Nachrichtenflaute haben
aber es ist, sollte klar sein, dass da halt seit vielen, vielen Jahren Geheimverträge ausgehandelt werden auf internationaler Ebene, um einfach diese ganze äh wir hauen auf die urheberrechtsverletzer Nummern drauf,
eine neue Basis zu stellen. Das ist sehr umstritten, zu Recht und ja, da müssen wir, glaube ich, nochmal ein bisschen auch die Geschichte erzählen.
Machen wir für den interessierten Leser ein paar Links einfach noch irgendwo mit rein in wer sich da schon mal einlesen möchte. Genau. Super.
Was noch passiert.
Ähm Netzneutralität gab's irgendwie, also nix spezielles, aber ich will das schon mal so ein bisschen kurz nochmal behandeln, das Thema, die im Europäischen Parlament wurde letzte Woche Donnerstag, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, war das dann
ähm,
Insta-Paper zeichnet jetzt das Datum nicht an. Hoffentlich ist das jetzt nicht irgendeine Meldung von vor drei Jahren. Ähm eine Entschließung zur Netznetralität verabschiedet. Das heißt, die fordern
Abgeordneten des Europaparlaments fordern die Europäische Kommission auf, sich stärker für die äh Durchsetzung des Prinzips der Netzneutralität einzusetzen.
Das ist also die fordern quasi die Kommission auf ähm.
Relativ bald zu prüfen, ob es nicht angerannt anscheint, einen gesonderten europäischen Rechtsrahmen zur Sicherung der Netznetralität irgendwie herzustellen,
da also Netzneutralität hatten wir ja schon mal kurz erklärt, was das ist. Also die, das Prinzip, das Pakete im Netz,
gleichberechtigt bleiben und man nicht irgendwie den einen oder den anderen Inhalt vor einem anderen priorisiert und vor allem nicht den Inhalt, den der ein Nutzer anfordert, vor dem den ein anderer Nutzer anfordert.
Präferiert, war das jetzt, kann man das noch richtig sagen? War der Satz noch in Ordnung?
Ähm die ganze Debatte ist äh in jeder Hinsicht sehr verwirrend, weil ich auch den Eindruck habe, dass äh viele, die daran teilnehmen, schnell diese Definition auch immer in eine Richtung drücken, wie es ihnen gerade so passt und,
äh für jeden da äh äh was anderes dahinter steckt bei Netzneutralität. Ich denke, der
der Urschleim, der äh dieses Begriffs, der bezieht sich wirklich einfach auf diese technische,
Realität, dass äh das Netz in seiner Weiterleitung der Daten zunächst einmal keinen Unterschied macht, ja. Äh die Debatte wird,
allerdings auch schon auf einem technischen Level. Meiner Auffassung nach, sehr schwierig.
Weil es ja nun beileibe nicht so ist, dass diese Neutralität heutzutage schon überall gegeben wäre, sondern Rauter und äh alle anderen äh am
eine Regelung des Datenstroms beteiligten Geräte haben natürlich einerseits die Möglichkeit, bestimmte Dinge zu sperren, also
getan wird, das steht jetzt nochmal auf einem anderen Blatt, aber können, tun sie das natürlich und natürlich auch drosseln. Und es gibt auch durchaus Provider, die haben natürlich auch ihre Schwierigkeiten, was weiß ich, so mit bitteren Traffic
Ja und äh wollen dann natürlich für andere irgendwie die Web Experience äh aufrecht erhalten. Da weiß man jetzt auch im Einzelnen gar nicht, was tatsächlich getan,
Wirt, ja, dass das möglich ist, ist auch klar. Und äh wie die Auswirkungen wären, wenn man da jetzt so ein ähm.
So ein absolutistische äh ihr dürft nicht mehr auf euer Netzwerkfluss Einfluss nehmen, was was davon die Auswirkungen werden, denke ich, lässt sich auch schwer ähm,
schwere Aussage zu treffen. Nichtsdestotrotz wird da halt viel drüber debattiert.
Genau, was nämlich der,
Unterschied irgendwie ist zwischen einem, sagen wir mal, Traffic irgendwie in die Bahn lenken, so dass es funktioniert. Ähm und dem, was, was warum jetzt irgendwie dieses Thema Netzneutralität irgendwie so dick wird, äh ist ja, dass,
Es ein Unterschied ist, ob ich zum Erhalt,
meines Netzwerkes irgendwie ein bisschen zuschaue, dass ich dann irgendwie mache ähm und zeitkritische Sachen irgendwie so ein bisschen,
zur Zufriedenheit meiner Nutzer irgendwie beschleunigen.
Telefonie ist zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel, ne? Da will man halt keine abreißenden Audioströme und äh mit Voice-Over-IP.
Versuche ich dann irgendwie mir Gedanken drüber zu machen. So,
Kritisch wird das Thema dann, wenn ich anfange zu sagen, ich bei mir vermischen sich da Interessen. Zum Beispiel ich bin irgendwie ein Provider, der auch Fernsehen anbietet,
Vielleicht ein großer, pinker Provider in Deutschland und habe dann ein Interesse daran, dass dieses Fernsehsignal, was ich da in HD übertrage, dass das unter allen Umständen ankommt,
und dass da die Zufriedenheit groß ist, während mir das vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so wichtig ist, bei konkurrierenden Anbietern.
Oder wenn ich ein ähm englischer Provider bin, wie die British Telekom und die BBC kommt irgendwann daher und sagt, hey, wir haben hier I-Player, ein total tolles Produkt. Könnt ihr mit Fernsehen und eure die Sendung nachschauen. Das ist so
quasi so die Mediathek in, so wie man sie sich wünschen würde von der von der BBC,
Und dann sagt der Provider irgendwann, na ja, Freunde, hier um Achter, merkt ihr ja auch, dass der dass der E-Player ein bisschen rüttelt. Aber pass mal auf, wenn ihr uns einen fünf Euro extra zahlt, äh oder fünf Pfund nehmen die ja da, dann ähm dann ruckelt der nicht mehr. Oder.
Schwierig knifflig wird sozusagen an der Stelle, wo man wo das eben nicht nur so ein Regulatorium auf Netzebene ist, sondern wo dann eben ein Anbieter der Versuchung erlegen könnte, auch na ja
können das ja hier einstellen und wenn du das jetzt für deinen Anschluss äh oder für deinen Angebot so oder so haben willst, dann kannst du uns ja dafür bezahlen, wir eröffnen jetzt hier den Wettbewerb, um die um den Datenfluss. Und da wird's schwierig.
Gleichzeitig könnte dann der Provider ja nicht nur bei dem äh Endkunden kassieren, sondern auch bei dem
bei den Anbietern, ja? Also gab's doch, glaube ich, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, hattest du das beim Mobile Max, ich habe das gar nicht mehr nachrecherchiert, dass es jetzt irgendwie die ersten Datenverträge gibt, wo Facebook, Traffic dann nicht mehr zählen soll. Hatte das nicht der,
irgendwie erzählt.
Ähm mich jetzt gerade nicht dran erinnern. Okay, dann. Kann aber sein.
Okay, dann äh sage ich's mal als dann nehme ich's nur als Gerücht Beispiel und sage, dass ich mir das jetzt gerade selber ausgedacht habe und dass jeder realistischen Grundlage entbehrt, dass man also zum es wäre ja eben sehr,
Das wäre natürlich denkbar, dass man dann eben sagt, okay, wir du kriegst hier ein Handy, Datenflat und Facebook Traffic zählt da nicht rein. Ja, das heißt, selbst wenn dein Volumen aufgebraucht ist, kannst du immer noch schön auf Facebook gehen. Das wäre natürlich dann für Facebook eine ganz interessante,
Sache, die gleichzeitig dann Facebooksmarkts Positionen, Marktpositionen nicht mag, Marktposition stark,
betonen würde. Und jetzt hat gerade der Anbieter einen Mobilfunkanbieter aus den USA bei einer
Marketing, Veranstaltung oder irgend so eine Technikkonferenz, seine Turbo Boost AP präsentiert. Und äh also quasi eine AP,
gegen die eine App, die jetzt auf meinem Smartphone läuft, ähm auslösen kann, dass mein Traffic präferiert wird,
haben das auch direkt als Beispiel, hatten sie da so einen LTE Videostream, also LTE ist ja die neue Generation,
Mobilfunknetze und haben dann gezeigt, guck mal hier, jetzt wird der äh pixelig, weil zu viele Nutzer.
Grade an diesen Masten hängen und dann drucken wir hier auf äh auf Turboboost,
dann wird unser Smartphone von allen anderen, die an diesen Masten hängen, im Vergleich zu allen anderen, wird dann bevorzugt. Und dann ähm rüttelt der Stream nicht mehr.
Und haben das dann irgendwie verglichen mit so einem feinen Feature wie so Appstore und Facebook und das wäre ja jetzt so das Neue eben das Handy mit Turboboost. Ähm.
Fragt sich natürlich so das das Kapazitätenproblem wird dadurch ja nicht gelöst, ja? Also bei bei allen anderen, die da sitzen, rückelt der äh Stream ja dann
noch mehr, weil einer grade den Turboboost angemacht hat. Und wenn den dann alle drücken, dann haben sie ja weiterhin das Problem, dass sie nicht liefern können, was da was da kommen soll. Also eine weiteres Problem ist für diese
diese Lazyness beim Netzausbau, die da teilweise.
Ja genau, da wird
da wird der Mangel äh monetarisiert, anstatt dass äh der Provider die entsprechenden Kapazitäten äh ausbaut, ne. Man stellt sich das mal vor, das würde jetzt im in der Wasserversorgung äh genauso sein, so äh ah, da kommt jetzt irgendwie zu Stoßzeiten, bei denen ich genug Wasser raus, dann
Kannst ja hier gegen aufpreis äh sozusagen
Dein Wasserfluss sicherstellen, dann tröpfelt's bei den anderen halt so ein bisschen, weil mehr können wir jetzt leider gerade nicht äh äh liefern und kommt doch mal klar und die anderen können doch auch mehr bezahlen so.
Erst wenn irgendwie alle mehr bezahlen, dann wird quasi die eigentliche Versorgung sichergestellt. Also das kann nicht die Antwort sein, ne.
Genau, also man ich merke, dass man genau, weil wenn man dann mit Providern Leuten spricht, die bei Providern arbeiten, die eben sagen, ja, wir müssen aber auch mal ein bisschen Traffic shapen oder so, äh dann
man da schneller an so eine Fundamentalgrenze, aber eigentlich ist es relativ offensichtlich, was irgendwie in dieser Debatte um Netzneutralität verhindert werden soll, nämlich
Ganz eindeutig so ein Turbo Bußknopf, ja, das ist also nichts anderes als ein erweiterte Gelddruckmaschine.
Also mit anderen Worten, das ist auch jetzt kein äh theoretische Chemere, die immer im Raum ist, sondern das ist wirklich eine reale Bedrohung und,
Ganzen immer befürchteten Szenarien finden jetzt auch statt und es ist einfach die Frage, ob die Politik da in der Lage ist, dem einen Riegel vorzuschieben
USA ist da, glaube ich, vom von der Businessorientierung her auch schon sehr viel weiter, aber.
Na da in den USA war ja vor allem dieser Fall, dass die ähm dass sie dass es ja die FCC-Regulation zur Netzneutralität gibt und die aber genau Mobilfunknetze ausspart.
Sie da nämlich gesagt haben, ja, da müssen wir damit tatsächlich realistische
oder realexistente Kapazitätsprobleme, was ja auch stimmt, ja, so ein Mast kann nur eine bestimmte Menge an Leuten versorgen. Man kriegt da nur eine gewisse Bandbreite drüber, irgendwann früher oder später gibt es notgedrungen interferenzen,
ähm das wird von Generation zu Generation Mobilfunknetz irgendwie immer weiter reduziert, aber letztendlich gibt es da eine Kapazitätsgrenze.
Ähm und deswegen haben sie gesagt, okay, im Mobilfunkbereich äh machen wir keine Netznetralitätsvorschreibungen. Und das Erste, was wir Ryzen daraus macht, ist halt irgendwie so, ey, Freunde, guckt mal hier, ihr könnt.
Also wenn das mal nicht die Büchse der Pandora ist, weil äh eigentlich
Katze da einen Schwanz, weil genau genommen ist es auch beim Festnetz so, dass es eine Kapazitätsbegrenzung gibt.
Die man nur dadurch beheben kann, dass man die Infrastruktur ausbaut und das ist ja auch nicht so, dass man jetzt Mobilfunk nicht auch die Infrastruktur ausbauen kann, sondern das ist vielleicht schwieriger, aber das ist ja nicht unmöglich und von daher
wird's knifflig, wenn man da mit einer generellen Ausnahme daherkommt.
Und vor allem natürlich, weil diese Mobilfunknetze sowieso irgendwie den Zukunftsmarkt darstellen.
Genau, also ich meine, es gibt Länder, so in Afrika oder so weiter. Ich meine, da hat da spielt Festnetz einfach überhaupt gar keine Rolle und äh.
Den den.
Hier ist es schwieriger zu erfühlen. Wir sind natürlich in Deutschland mit äh einer Festnetzqualität ähm gesegnet, die äh,
sich in anderen Ländern so nicht findet und von daher äh mag uns das alles etwas ferner sein, aber es heißt nicht, dass das Problem nicht genau so irgendwann hochkommt.
Ganz kurz bevor ich jetzt nachher missverstanden werde und sage es gäbe im Festnetz keine Kapazitätsgrenzen. Natürlich gibt's die auch, aber ich könnte immer noch mal einfach ein weiteres Kabel hinlegen und einen weiteren Rauter aufstellen, was bei ähm
Funk eben dann irgendwann nicht mehr möglich ist. Ja, dann ist die Luft Luft irgendwann voll.
Dann flattert's auf allen Frequenzen und dann ist die, dann ist die Luft voll. Das habe ich irgendwann auch mal beim, bei einem Artikel auf Netzpolitik so geschrieben, was,
ausgelacht.
Hier lacht ja keiner.
Zumindest höre ich's nicht.
Ja, letzter Punkt vielleicht, die Politik in Deutschland.
Ja
Mal interessieren. Wir hatten äh letztes Mal fast einen Fokus ausschließlich auf ferne Länder, aber ist ja nicht so, dass hier nichts passieren würde. Ein,
Artikel in der Globusphäre hat äh das Interesse auf sich gezogen.
Ja und zwar äh vierter bis sechster Dezember findet der Bundesparteitag der SPD in Berlin statt.
Und ähm jetzt muss man dazu sagen, wenn die, wenn die so einen Bundesparteitag machen, da gibt's so viele Anträge, dass sie eine eigene Antragskommission haben ähm
die quasi so ein bisschen diese Anträge alle sortieren soll, ja, dass da sind eventuell Wiederholungen dabei oder ähm äh,
Also hauptsächlich geht's dann um Wiederholungen wahrscheinlich, ja? Und dann sagen sie, okay, wir sortieren da jetzt mal so ein bisschen vor,
Und daraus machen sie dann eine Empfehlung. Da ist jetzt am Ende bei der SPD ein äh ein Papier rausgekommen, was irgendwie siebenhundertsiebzig Seiten umfasst. Das sind die Anträge.
Nachsortierung. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ich hab's jetzt nicht gelesen und auf Wiederholung gecheckt, aber es sieht so aus, dass das Dokument, was ich da gerade hatte, die Anträge nachsortierung sind. Ja, da gibt's also eine Menge Anträge, die,
So und da muss es also offensichtlich auch so eine Antragskommission geben, damit wende mich jetzt sowas passiert, wie jetzt grade auch geschehen ist, dass die jungen Sozialisten einen Antrag stellen.
Gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und weitere,
mehrere Ortsverbände und Arbeitskreis der sozialdemokratischen Juristen äh stellen ähnlich lautende Anträge, nämlich alle den Antrag äh äh
gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ja? Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist mit sozialdemokratischen Prinzipien nicht vereinbar und die verwarnen,
Ausdrücklich vor der Form zu Nichte machen, der vertrauensbildenden Arbeit der Netzpolitiker in der Partei, ja, die sich jetzt irgendwie jahrelang,
offensichtlich bemüht haben, den.
Ruf der Partei irgendwie wieder herzustellen, wer weiß wie erfolgreich sie dabei waren. Aber Fakt ist, es gibt eine ganze Menge ähm Anträge gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und es gibt einen Antrag vom,
Ortsverband Eimsbüttel Nord.
Und äh dieser äh dieser Antrag lautet nicht auf ähm gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sondern Vorratsdatenspeicherung eindämmen,
Ja, man sollte also die Privatsphäre und Überwachung irgendwie in Einklang bringen und ähm falls das nicht gelingen sollte.
Menschen verträglich gestalten.
Naja, dann also falls sie, falls sie es nicht schaffen, dass Menschen verträglich zu gestalten, dann sollte man ablehnen. Und das hat diese Antragskommission unter Olaf Scholz,
zum Anlass genommen zu sagen, na ja, pass mal auf alle, die sagen, wir sind Gegenvorratsdatenspeicherung,
subsumieren wir, also oder quasi lehnen wir ab unter Hinweis darauf, dass es ja schon den Vorratsdatenspeicherung eindämmen gibt. Und ähm deswegen kommen die alle nicht mehr zum Zuge.
Sondern wir empfehlen diesen.
Antrag des äh Ortsverbands Eimsbüttel Nord und zwar in seiner Langversion. Und in der Langversion ist er nochmal irgendwie äh kritischer und das einzige also kritisch im Sinne von.
Kritisch für die Demokratie oder für für.
Schwieriger zu bewerten.
Schwieriger zu bewerten, ähm weil da der einzige Unterschied eigentlich zur CDU Parteilinie ist, zu sagen, statt sechs Monaten Speicherung drei Monate, das müsste ja wohl reichen.
Und das ist quasi so so verwässert sich quasi vom Weg, von der Basis durch die Antragskommission in den Bundesparteitag nach oben ähm so,
quasi der Wille, der da offensichtlich von vielen Leuten da ist, ja? Und jetzt quasi scheint es im Moment so zu sein.
Das war ja ein bemerkenswerter äh Blogartikel, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, ist auch dieser dieser äh dieser Wahlkreis auch.
Eh irgendwie komisch, ja?
Ist eh komisch, war lange, lange Zeit an der SPD, Bastion, dann wurde äh dort der ähm,
idat, äh ich habe das äh nicht mehr im Kopf ausgetauscht, dann ging irgendwie dieser Wahlkreis auch Flöten und.
Irgendwie äh also dieser Blogbeitrag erzeugt so ein wenig das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ob das,
Richtige Gefühl ist an der Stelle, ich kann das einfach nicht bewerten, aber so liest man das da raus,
Ort ist, wo man irgendwie auch versucht, da einfach eine eine Agenda durchzubringen.
Die jetzt einfach nicht dieselben Basiskontakt hat, wie das die ganzen Anträge zu haben scheinen, also,
kurz gesagt, es macht so den Eindruck, als ob eigentlich die Basis der SPD mittlerweile, zumindest in den Teilen, die sich da wirklich drüber Gedanken machen, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ablehnt,
dass man aber eben ich will jetzt hier nicht zu viel unterstellen, ja, aber es ist,
macht einfach nur den Eindruck, dass äh es einfach Kräfte gibt
die der Meinung sind, man müsste ja hier eine EU konforme oder CDU konforme oder was auch immer äh konformer äh Linie fahren, die diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung einfach am Leben erhält
weil man sich sonst nicht als Regierungsfähig ansieht.
Das ist jetzt schon mal schon mal viel reininterpretiert, was wir ja eigentlich nicht tun wollten, aber ich sage nur, das ist der Eindruck, den mir dieser äh Artikel gegeben hat und das ist eigentlich schon ein Skandal. Von wem war dieser Artikel?
Wolfgang Michael ähm ich weiß ja der sagt ja, kommt da zu so einem ähnlichen Schluss, wie du ihn sagt, ähm,
dass also diese Antragskommission so als bewährte Filter um einerseits,
Parteispitzen von dem Zug vor den Zumutungen der Basis zu schützen und andererseits die Basis davon abzuhalten, Dinge zu fordern, die über EU-Richtlinien hinausgehen, ja? Und das ist ja genau diese vorhersprechung, hat ja noch diese EU-Komponente da mit drin,
und äh auf EU-Ebene, die Europaabgeordneten der SPD haben damals ja dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung zugestimmt. Das heißt, ähm,
Da gibt's also so für ganz viele verschiedene komische Gründe, warum jetzt da offensichtlich dieses
man kann da, glaube ich, schon sagen, dass da ein Spiel gespielt wird mit diesen Anträgen, ne, wenn irgendwie sechs Ortsverbände oder sieben Gruppen irgendwie fordern,
hier abschaffen und du subsumierst die unter dem unter dem Knetgummi Paragraphen, der aus irgendwelche äh Knetgummi eintragt, der irgendwo außer.
Nichts äh hervorgezaubert wird.
Ja, es sind äh doch sehr undemokratisches Instrument an der Stelle, ne, weil man hat da halt eine Kommission, die,
Basisfächer, Daten auch immer entscheidet, naja, das nehmen wir, das nehmen wir nicht, ja? Und da gibt's dann,
demokratische Willens und äh Meinungsbildungsprozesse, die da äh vielleicht jahrelang abgelaufen sind auf irgendeiner örtlichen Ebene und dann prallt das halt wach an der Stelle ab, ohne dass sie da groß mitreden können, ne.
Und wenn ich jetzt jetzt spekuliere ich grade mal so ein bisschen, weil wenn jetzt also die Falle ist ja eigentlich, wenn jetzt dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung eindämmen, Antrag irgendwie abgestimmt werden würde.
Und es stünde kein Vorratsdatenspeicherung gegen keine Vorzeitenspeicherungsantrag im Raum, dann ist ein Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgegner, kann entweder dann diesen eindämmen Antrag ablehnen, dann bleibt alles beim Alten,
oder er kann den ein, der im Antrag annehmen.
Da bleibt auch alles beim Alten.
Ja gut drei statt sechs Monate.
Ja
dann alles, ja. Obwohl eigentlich eine Mehrheit der Anträge, ja, ob das eine Mehrheit der Leute ist, sage ich, lasse ich mal offen, eine Mehrheit der Anträge eigentlich relativ klar sagt, das einzige Modell, was wir uns vorstellen können, ist keine VDS.
Gut, wir werden also sehen, wie sich das jetzt gestaltet. Ich glaube, dass da der ähm dass da noch einiges an Auseinandersetzungen stattfinden wird und ich will mal hoffen, dass sich diese Situation ähm klärt.
Mhm. Das wollen wir hoffen.
Viel allzu viel Zeit gibt's dann nicht mehr, aber äh wollen wir es mal hoffen, ja.
Gut, Dinos, ich glaube, wir haben's. Das war's. Ja, okay. Wenn wir nichts Wichtiges vergessen haben, haben wir natürlich, aber.
Wir machen die weiteren Themen dann einfach den.
In der nächsten Woche. Genau und halten's hier schön äh übersichtlich. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir sagen tschüss.
Auf Wiedersehen und herzlichen Dank für euer Ohr.
Genau, bis dann.